tenemos la proporción x 9 sobre 12 es
igual a 2 sobre 3 y queremos encontrar
el valor de x que cumple con esta
proporción hay muchas maneras de hacer
esto la mayoría de la gente cuando ve
una proporción como ésta se le ocurre
hacer la multiplicación cruzada 3 por x
menos 9 es igual a 12 por 2 lo cual es
correcto déjame escribirlo por aquí
tenemos 3 por x menos 9 es igual a 2 por
12 2 por 12 del lado izquierdo
distribuyendo el 3 nos da 3 por x menos
27 que es igual a 24 ahora sumamos 27 a
ambos lados que tenemos déjame
escribirlo sumamos 27 del lado izquierdo
y suma 227 el lado derecho del lado
izquierdo se cancelan estos términos nos
queda 3x y del lado derecho resulta 24
27 es 51 ahora dividiendo a ambos lados
entre 3x es igual a 17 así es que 17
menos 9 es 88 sobre 12
al 2 sobre 3 nuestra respuesta es
correcta otra manera de hacer esto en
vez de hacer la multiplicación cruzada
sería eliminar de entrada este 12 que
tenemos aquí para lo cual multiplicamos
toda la ecuación por 12 así es que
multiplicando por 12 ambos lados aquí se
cancelan los 12 del lado izquierdo y nos
queda tan solo x menos 9 y del lado
derecho tenemos dos tercios de 12 2
tercios de 12 es igual a 8 podemos hacer
de hecho la multiplicación dos tercios
que multiplica a 12 sobre 1
simplificamos aquí 12 y 32 entre 3 es
igual a 4 3 entre 3 es igual a 1 para
terminar simplemente con 2 por 4 igual a
8 y ahora sumamos 9 a ambos lados eso es
lo extraordinario del álgebra no importa
el camino que tomes mientras sea
lógicamente consistente vas a llegar al
mismo resultado y aquí de nueva cuenta
obtenemos x igual a 17 y también podrías
multiplicar ambos lados por 12 ya ambos
lados por 3 y va a ser equivalente a
esta multiplicación cruzada que hicimos
hagamos uno más aquí tenemos otra
proporción pero en esta ocasión la equis
está en el denominador pero así como
hicimos antes si lo queremos podemos
hacer la multiplicación cruzada pero
para creamos de dónde sale esta
multiplicación cruzada que no es algo
mágico que estás haciendo sino que estás
haciendo operaciones válidas a ambos
lados de la ecuación en realidad lo que
estamos haciendo es multiplicar ambos
lados por ambos denominadores así es que
tenemos este 8 aquí en el denominador
del lado izquierdo y para eliminarlo
tenemos que multiplicar este término por
así es que multiplicamos este término
por 8 pero para mantener la igualdad de
la ecuación también tenemos que
multiplicar por ocho el lado derecho de
manera similar similarmente si queremos
eliminar este x + 1 de este denominador
tenemos que multiplicar por x + 1 esta
expresión pero pero nuevamente para que
no se altere la igualdad hay que
multiplicar por x + 1 también del lado
izquierdo esto que hemos hecho es
equivalente a la multiplicación cruzada
estos 8 se cancelan del lado derecho se
cancelan los x más 1 por lo que ahora la
ecuación queda
izquierdo x + 1 que multiplica 7 x 1 que
multiplica 7 el 7 luego poner antes para
posteriormente distribuir el producto y
esto va a ser igual al producto de 5 por
8 5 por 8 y observa esto es lo que
hubieras obtenido de haber hecho la
multiplicación cruzada la multiplicación
cruzada es una manera rápida de
multiplicar una ecuación por ambos
denominadores tenemos que 7 x x 1 es
igual a 5 por 8 y ahora hacemos álgebra
para resolver la ecuación del lado
izquierdo distribuimos el 7 para obtener
7 x + 7 que es igual a 40 ahora restamos
7 de ambos lados vamos a restar 7 el
lado izquierdo y 7 el lado derecho para
obtener del lado izquierdo estos 7 se
cancelan nos queda 7 x que es igual a 33
dividimos entre 7 para despejar x estos
7 se cancelan y nos queda que x es igual
a 33 séptimos lo cual podemos escribir
como cuatro enteros
5 séptimos y así hemos concluido